نشاهد هذه الصور
المتداوله ايضا
لمواجهات بين الشرطه الفرنسيه
ومحتجين ايضا
كذلك اذا هذه الصور
ربما لرشقات ايضا من المحتجين باتجاه رجال
الشرطه الذين يقفون امام بعض المحال ربما
التجاريه ومنع تكسير هذه المحاله التجاريه
صدامات اذا بين الشرطه الفرنسيه ومحتجين
في العاصمه الفرنسيه باريس هذا المشهد كنا
قد تابعناه كذلك ايضا في مدينه ناانت
الفرنسيه
وايضا في مدينه كذلك ليون جنوب فرنسا
الصوره
تتكرر المشهد ايضا يتكرر للمواجهات بين
الشرطه الفرنسيه
والمحتجين في باريس المحتجون المؤيدون
ايضا
لاضرابات النقابات العماليه في باريس
وهذه طبعا النقابات التي خرجت الى الشارع
محتجه على رفع سن التقاعد قانون رفع سن
التقاعد من الحكومه الفرنسيه من 62 عاما
الى 64 عاما